you've endorsed joe biden you and i have
connected on a number of political
topics
uh that we're both passionate about and
i remember you saw
i saw a tweet from you championing local
journalism which i could not agree more
with
uh universal health care and and
universal basic income you think should
be on the table now
given the nature of the crisis we're in
the midst of uh
did you have like a an arc politically
is it something that
you and your family were interested in
from a while ago or or did you
just uh start paying more attention more
recently
uh now i've always been engaged one of
the things i admire about the nba
players is they're a lot more active
than i was at that age i was pretty
self-centered at that point worried
about my own career
so i think i've been more active but i
was always engaged i grew up in a
you know my parents are conservative um
for me the ark was as i was i was always
socially pretty liberal you know i
just didn't understand why anybody cared
if you were
sleeping with somebody of the same sex
or what the
color of your skin was or any of those
things um but
i think i've certainly had an arc
in terms of economic issues
um you know i think at one point i was a
um
you know balance the budget guy
um and still am to a degree
might the difference between me and and
conservatives would probably be i'd
raise taxes and bring in more money so
we could help more people
um but recently right before
you started running for president so
these two things
really propelled me my wife and i
had watched it's probably a three or
four year old documentary that robert
reich did
um when he was teaching at cattle he
still is
and you know he was talking about
trickle down doesn't work yep you know
going up building the middle class so
people have more money to
spend that's what builds an economy
and helps everyone and so we watched
that
made all kinds of sense trickle down has
never made any sense to me whatsoever
like
this idea that they're gonna create jobs
up here like
i know i've never even run a business
but if i run a restaurant the only
reason
i'm gonna hire more waiters or
waitresses is i have more customers
like you can give me a tax break and put
another hundred thousand in my pocket
i'm not going out to hire anybody i'm
not gonna hire some more people unless
everyone's
gonna hire somebody if i have the need
to hire them so
robert reich made sense to me if now i
have more customers in my restaurant
i do better i hire more people they do
better
and so i watched that that made a lot of
sense i learned a lot from that
and then i mean within months
if if not even weeks after watching that
you're on stage talking about universal
basic
income which that idea goes exactly with
that
putting more money in people's pockets
and
so i will say that's a more recent thing
to me
um within the last year of saying
wow this makes a lot of sense it's it's
not only
more humane fairer to people in our
society
but to me that helps everybody including
the people at the top
yep yeah if you're running a business
you know what you need you need
customers with money to show
up uh you know and if you're in an
environment right now where everyone is
being sent home
uh like it's like who are you gonna
profit from you know like
you you look outside we can't all be
amazon you know i guess amazon's still
doing all right
uh so uh so this is the trickle up
economy and i i saw the same documentary
you saw by
um with uh robert reich and um he's been
a
very powerful and consistent voice in
this direction
keeps on writing books keeps on pounding
the table making the case
and the economy's just gotten more and
more extreme over time
it was the most extreme winner take all
economy in the history of the world
pre-pandemic
and then the pandemic just turned
everything
up to 11. like it just sped everything
up
well and here in central florida
we have felt it about as much as anybody
because
you know we don't have a lot of business
here i mean it's a tourism business and
we're in the service
you know it's a service economy so we
got a lot of people
working low-wage jobs here we have the
biggest affordable housing crisis
in the united states um because we're
playing we're paying people
10 12 15 an hour
and that's it and there's there's no
upward mobility
when you're running a ride at disney
world you know
and so we can make our unemployment
numbers look okay but those are not high
paying
jobs and then when people quit
traveling and quit going to those things
in a pandemic
i mean it has really really been bad
i know the local the biggest local
food shelter uh in the area has
you know been doing about triple the
number of meals
that they normally do it's been really
really rough and it hasn't been
you know you would you would think i
mean for everybody this pandemic's been
rough
but you would think when you go through
a crisis that it should be
shared it should be a shared grief
and a shared adversity and that's not
the way it's been you know
bernie sanders treats tweets out you
know one of your former opponents like
at least every other day tweets out how
much
some of these billionaires have made
during the pandemic
and you know their net worth is going up
and we've got all these people who can't
eat and that led to your tweet today
which
is my favorite and we'll probably be
going
up on a sign in my room when i can get
the calligraphy done about
you know and i'm not reading the quote
right now but imagine
having the wherewithal to
you know solve people's problems
and then you don't do it i you know it's
i can't solve the problems that jeff
bezos can solve
but i've been lucky enough i can solve a
few people's problems
and you have to do it i i love that
tweet i've sent it to i retweeted it but
people not on twitter i was sending out
to everybody today um and i think
that's where it should be we should
really be a community a community of
people who are helping others
but we can't help we can't count on
charity that's why to me
ubi and things like that like we can't
depend on
charity we need systems in place that
will help people through
this so well you know
one of the reasons why i think that
there's something universal about sports
and there's something universal about
coaching
where you form a community with your
team you know you're part of a group
you're on this together
and then you naturally want the same
kind of thing for our country when
you're going through a hard time it's
not like
the team's going through a hard time and
you just start ignoring people or
singling people out or just like pretend
some people don't exist it's like okay
who's uh
who's on the team like you know let's
come together uh and here in america
we have to all get on the same team
really like that there's just
too many problems that
are facing folks for us to just continue
all of the this strange
uh strange
trend of just everyone blaming the other
side for everything
uh for turning on each other and
singling each other out
it's it's painful for me too stan
like it's painful for me to see our
country go through this time
and um have all these self-inflicted
wounds really
you know it's like like this would be a
very rough time even if we did
everything right
and i would say that for most of us
looking at it from the outside the nba
was an incredibly high functioning
organization
and did just about everything it could
do right right um
at the bubble and then it's in the sharp
contrast to most of our other
institutions where everyone's looking
around being like who's supposed to be
running the show who's supposed to be
leading this uh the federal government
um like has not been leading
uh you know and and i think you're a
coach you're like a leader of man you're
a community builder
uh i think it's one of the reasons why
people love sports love the nba is that
there's something very human about that
uh and it feels like that's what the
country needs
right now yeah to me and i'm sure to you
too because i've heard you
speak a lot um the most frustrating
thing is
we have the wealth in this country we
have
the resources to do this and to take
care of all of our people now
there's countries in the world that are
very very poor
and don't have the wherewithal to take
care of
the problems in their country we have
the wealth to do that
and we just don't have the systems in
place
and we don't have the will or
to make the sacrifice to make this a
more
equal society where everybody can share
in this
and that's what frustrates me if it was
a
shared experience and we just don't have
the money to help people
we do we have the money to do it
we everyone knows it now too stan when i
was running for president people
would be like oh like how do we pay for
that and then we just watch
uh our congress write a 2.2 trillion
dollar check
mainly to the like the biggest companies
and then you're just like oh
we could have done this the whole time
you know you can do it i mean you can do
universal basic income you can do
medicare for all
or some form of universal health care
you know whatever's best i'm not uh i've
said to people like i
i'm not i'm not as smart as you or
bernie sanders or elizabeth warren and i
haven't gotten as deep into that
um but those possibilities are out there
and why we would choose as a wealthy
country
to have the levels of poverty we have to
have the number of people
without health care and without health
insurance that we have
is just mind-boggling to me and
it's a failure in our moral character
in our country and there's no other way
to put that
i mean you just you can't sugarcoat that
you have the resources to take care of
these problems you refuse to do it
your moral character is lacking i'm not
like that's not a partisan thing that's
that's just the truth yeah
and uh it should be apolitical to stan
it should just be human
uh and unfortunately right now our
politics has become
uh inseparable from
uh from the media narratives uh from
frankly the corporate interests because
so many of our politicians
just have very very rich corporate
interests whispering in their ear all
the time
um i'd love to to change it i think we
have a chance to change it
in some measure after trump is out and
joe and kamala are in
i believe some very big things will be
on the table and really then the
challenge is going to be
can we get enough done in let's call it
four years
uh that people feel like we have
genuinely started to
come together and rebuild that trust not
based upon
statements but upon actually improving
people's day-to-day lives and reality
like that that to me is going to be the
challenge over the next number of years
because if we fail in that
then people's mistrust and
that that disintegration of uh the sense
of community is just going to
accelerate as well i feel like we have a
window of opportunity here
that we have to take full advantage of i
may
play a role in that um but that's that's
where my head is going now
yeah and as you know i mean i i think
people are realistic we're not going to
solve all the problems within a within a
four-year term but i think
we can start to solve them and i think
we can
show people in very concrete terms like
you say not in statements but in things
getting done
we can show people the possibilities of
what a better society
could look like for everybody in this
country
and we could set a direction of starting
to get there
that to me is what can happen and that
takes concrete things it's not just
statements but
we start to turn around and we get more
money in people's pocket
um heading toward hopefully at least
some form of universal basic income and
at least we start working toward getting
more people
health insurance and you know all of
these problems
are we going to get it turned 180
degrees
in in four years no that's not realistic
but
can you turn it 60 degrees 70 degrees
and give people the feeling we're on the
right
track we can do these things we have the
resources
we have the leadership we can do these
things
that's what i'm hoping will happen over
the next four years i'm not
i'm not expecting joe biden kamala
harris people like you
i hope in the administration that's a
great hope for us
i'm not expecting like hey they took
over january of 21 and it's february now
yep we've got it all
i got my universal basic income check
and we're ready to go
yeah even if we do everything right
you're right that a lot of it's going to
be have we
made headway have we made progress and
it's a little bit like if you take over
a team you're not going to turn around
being like we're going to be champions
that's right like this year it's like
look give me a few years and hopefully
we'll have a direction we'll have a
culture we'll have a sense of trust
a sense of confidence um that that's
certainly
uh my vision for the next number of
years uh well stan
uh such a pleasure connecting with you
and a privilege i've been an admirer of
uh you and your work for a long time um
you're a force for good the force for
community uh force for progress in our
country
and i'm looking forward to finding ways
that we can work together one of my
dreams is that
uh that universal basic income takes
root and communities around the country
and i think that people like you are
going to be a big part of it
i would love to help you in any way i
mean i i think that
you know my big biggest issue has just
been
justice and equality in every area
racial justice
you know women's rights uh
you know lgbtq rights but economic
justice
is one that just cuts across all of
those and for
everybody and makes a true difference in
people's
lives and so if you ever need my help
even in a small way
i would be i would be happy to get on
board because
i think you've shown us a blueprint now
we just have to have the uh
political will and courage to uh to give
it a shot
well thank you stan thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode